hello folks and welcome back to the show
that today features the biggest battle
of bulging biceps in the history of
versus no it's not going to be these
little water pistols competing it's the
bazooka show because it's arnold
schwarzenegger taking on dwayne the rock
johnson both fellows have a history of
performing well on this year program but
now they find themselves faced with
their toughest opponent ever even
tougher than satan who did fall at the
hands of arnold but the rock punched an
earthquake so this is going to be a fun
one kids in one corner you have a
multi-time mr olympian champion from
austria who dabbles in movies when he's
not running the state of california in
the other a famous wrestler whose
penchant for beating up baddies is
almost as potent as his sense of smell
neither arnold nor dwayne are used to
losing very much so someone is in for a
surprise i'm on gold medal
you're afraid i'm gonna kick your little
mermaid ass all over this course in
front of all these people tell me what i
must do
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
iconic moments round four franchise
ability and then we'll do a wild card
round that the rock hopes involves giant
crocodile taming with these two
behemoths nothing is out of the realm of
possibility except the tie dwayne
johnson has already defeated his good
buddy kevin hart in a previous episode
of verses and the terminator once
shredded robocop on this very program
but now they're going head-to-head it's
the t-800 vs hercules conan taking on
hobbs and most violently it's going to
be kindergarten cop brawling against the
tooth fairy let's get it on i don't want
to do this round one box office
if ever there lived two dudes who didn't
need to be on a giant screen to look big
it's arnold and dwayne but their dreams
of movie stardom wouldn't budge and as a
result they become two of the biggest
a-list attractions in hollywood history
the rock is one of the very few movie
stars today that can open a film all by
himself and if an existing movie
collection needs a boost he's been
called franchise viagra i scratch my
back with a whale's dick but the action
star template was molded most notably by
schwarzenegger who came into prominence
in tinseltown in the late 1970s and
would go on to be the most dominant
force in film for well over a decade
maybe two decades since arnold's box
office peak occurred 30 years before
dwayne's we've adjusted for inflation
meaning that yes arnold's numbers are in
fact on steroids but it's legal here i'm
the commissioner of the show and i
okayed it mainly because the other guy's
nickname is viagra and i'm pretty sure
that's a performance-enhancing drug but
even with a level playing field arnold
might be marching uphill most of his
biggest flicks were rated r i know
because i snuck into some of them hi one
for uh
beethoven please
despite arnold's rapid rise to movie
stardom in the 1980s only two of his top
10 all-time grossers are from that
decade the bulk of his biggest box
office beasts was in the 1990s including
the best of the best terminator 2
judgement day at 457 million dollars
domestically followed by true lies 328
million bucks and total recall which
hauled in
million earth dollars in 1990. twins and
predator are his two best efforts in the
1980s and they would combine to add over
400 million dollars to his domestic
receipts resume all told arnold
schwarzenegger has done 30 theatrically
released films which have totaled 3.9
billion clams for a domestic average of
130 million bucks per movie that is a
lot of chiseled butt cheeks in the seats
the rock flexes his glutes in this round
as well as his franchise boosting
formula has made jumanji and the fast
and furious two of the biggest
properties of this millennium jumanji
welcomed to the jungles his all-time
breadwinner at 404 million dollars here
in the states and that's followed
closely by fast seven at 375 million and
then the jumanji sequel the next level
at 313 million bucks and speaking of
valuable properties i hear the kids like
those disney animated movies and moana
also figures into his top five box
office draws raking in 359 million
dollars back in 2016. his star power is
so muscular that he helped steer jungle
crews to over 100 million dollars in
theaters during a pandemic and it
already got a green light for a sequel
to date the rock has done 35
theatrically released flicks that have
hauled in 4.64 billion dollars for an
arnold topping average of 136 million
dollars domestically anytime your pile
of cash is bigger than schwarzenegger's
you're doing something right it just
happens naturally and for johnson that
something right is timing now he's had
big hits on his own without a franchise
helping him but it's only moana and san
andreas of those flicks that are on his
top 10 films in terms of bucks generated
everything else was an established
property before he joined it again they
probably needed him more than vice versa
but still timing is everything meanwhile
arnold established every one of his
properties on his top 10 list with the
lone exception of batman and robin and
i'll be honest i don't really think we
needed that one i like the freezing
jokes i do cry therapy every day but no
thank you both arnold and dwayne have
proven themselves worthy of their huge
stardom in this round but in a race this
close i gotta take the one who set the
trend for all muscly action heroes to
follow arnold schwarzenegger built his
most famous franchises from the ground
up and in a time when the terminators
predators and red heats of the world
were getting nothing but r ratings so
think of all the additional coin he
would have generated if those nerd do
well kids like me coulda bought a ticket
to the movie we were actually going to
see and by the way don't try that at
home don't do it today you little kids
it was a simpler time back then and
after the movie let out we had to walk
back to school 10 miles uphill in the
snow arnold wins round one and goes up
one nothing
round two tomato meter slash audience
score sure it's easy to get in the gym
at five a.m every day then head to set
to shoot for 16 hours straight while
being force-fed chicken breast every 45
minutes to maintain your bulk for a
gigantic action movie but will the
critics like the result in the case of
arnold and dwayne sometimes while
neither fella has a fresh average on the
tomato meter one of the two does sneak
into fresh territory on the audience
score metric you wanna know who it is
you gotta keep watching it's the rock
i'm not good at teases he's fresh it's
63 on the audience score that's thanks
in large part to his disney family fair
like jungle cruise at 92 percent and
moana at 89 percent and if it's family
you like then you're gonna love his fast
and furious entries fast five is it
eighty-three percent fast six is it
eighty-four percent fast seven
eighty-two percent those aren't the
actual titles of all the movies but
trust me they're very speedy and
incredibly angry arnold might get a
little furious at his audience score for
only getting him a 48 career average
yeesh what did that guy do to you dear
moviegoer
oh right batman and robin and junior
which were at 19 and 22 respectively but
he also gave us all-time audience
delights like terminator 2 at 94 percent
predator at 87
and the og terminator at 89
good guy bad guy we just love
schwarzenegger and sunglasses apparently
even terminator dark fate is at 82 on
the audience score and now we head over
to the critical section of percentages
the tomato meter many an action star has
defeated aliens terrorists and cobra
commander only to find that the critics
didn't really jive with the adventure
and while it's true that neither weight
lifter today has an overall fresh
average they both have many a highlight
at the top of the tomato meter including
one movie scoring a perfect 100 percent
you want to know what it is you gotta
wait i'll just say it the terminator not
the judgment day one the original 1984
flick that put arnold linda hamilton
michael bean and some guy named jim
cameron into the hollywood map of stars
it's at a hundred percent like toy story
range the immediate sequel t2 isn't far
behind at 93 percent and terminator 3
rise of the machines is nowhere close
but still fresh it's at 69
and maybe that number would be in the
90s if claire danes had suddenly
remembered she can fly a plane earlier
in the movie all told arnold's career
tomato meter ravage is only 47 with his
highlights weighed down thanks to end of
days where he fought hell at 11
and batman and robin where he fought any
temperature above 32 degrees at 12
percent maybe critics just liked the
heat
the rock gets closer to fresh for his
career thanks to gems like moana at 95
percent and fighting with my family
where he played the rock at 93 percent
both jumanjis and comedies like the
other guys and central intelligence land
squarely in the regularly bathed
territory somewhere in the 70s i wanted
to spotlight some of the quality yucks
he's provided to us over the years
because the rock might be fresh for his
entire career if not for comedic
disasters like baywatch at 17 and be
cool with 30 nevertheless dwayne the
tiny boulder johnson has a lifetime
average of 52 percent on the tomato
meter so if we were just doing kids
movies i don't know i think arnold might
win kindergarten cop is at 51 on the
tomato meter against the tooth fairy 17
but that tooth fairy does have julie
andrews in it and the hills are alive
with the sound of competition the rock
takes round two and ties the game at one
a piece
round three iconic moments
we're into the thick of battle now and
dwayne johnson is adjudicating himself
very well against a much more
experienced opponent and if you think
that arnold schwarzenegger has an
advantage in a round called iconic
moments simply because he's had a
30-year head start on the rock
you're probably right but consider this
johnson is partially responsible for an
iconic moment the two fellas share from
his breakout action hit the run down
story time with uncle mark the rock and
the rundown director peter berg had the
opportunity to do lunch which is how
fancy people eat lunch with arnold
schwarzenegger while production of the
rundown was underway so this launch
probably involved a crap ton of protein
but also featured a question would
arnold consider making a cameo in this
movie not only did schwarzenegger say
yes but he was the one that suggested
the scene be shot later that day within
minutes they're back on set filming
arnold exiting a nightclub as dwayne was
entering and arnold's line in that movie
good luck in there is somewhat of a
passing of the torch moment was he
wishing that character good luck or was
he passing the torch of this planet's
biggest action star onto johnson and in
the years since the rock has proven
himself worthy of that honor i also
bring up the rundown because dude takes
down an entire army in it sure stifler
helps but that's pretty much one guy
defeating an armada however arnold can
also brag about besting an entire
military outfit in commando and as cool
as both of those epic climactic clashes
are the best part of either one of those
flicks is the calm before the storm when
arnold loads up at a sporting goods
store that apparently sells rocket
launchers ah the 1980s that decade
featured some of the best moments of
schwarzenegger's legendary career even
if the movies themselves are somewhat
forgettable red heat had an awesome bus
chase sequence and raw deal has a
loading up for the action scene that
rivals commando the running man does
hold up freakishly rather well and big
shout out to game show host richard
dawson for being a good sport buzzsaw
and sub-zero gave arnold all he wanted
in their fight scenes although i do have
to admit ten-year-old mark was
disappointed when he rented this one
from video update only to find that it
wasn't the mortal kombat sub-zero
walking through that door but if it's
truly iconic moments you want then we
gotta bring in the classics the
terminator franchise has some of the
best time travel sci-fi action you'll
find anywhere including the police
station blowout and the og and the big
rig chase in t2 i also give points to
the truck chase in terminator 3 one of
the more redeeming points of that flick
still the coolest scene in any
terminator movie for me is judgement day
when sarah connor sees her nightmare
t-800 and oh my what we have to trust it
this time and prepare your kleenex for
the end of that film the thumbs up still
gets me every time as for the rock i
can't decide which ridiculous moment is
more iconic is it him making an
impossible jump that would make david
lee roth jealous in skyscraper or is it
when hubris tells him and sam jackson
that they can make a similar jump in the
other guys only to splat on the ground i
think i'm going with the slightly more
realistic one in the other guys and
speaking of zany action that's why we
keep coming back to see fast and furious
movies in droves and when the rock
joined the family in fast five the ante
was upped considerably his battle
against vin diesel's dom toretto might
have set the record for shattered glass
in a fight scene breaking the previous
record held by die hard and he would go
on to have such memorable sequences as
driving an ambulance onto a drone
tangling with jason statham and then
idris elba's black superman in hobson
shaw and my favorite scene of all in
fate of the furious when he's racing on
a glacier and opens the driver's side
door to gently nudge a rocketing torpedo
on a slightly different course
should be viewed in every driver's ed
class both these giants can do some
memorable comedy too you know before
this i used to work in an orange juice
factory but i got canned
couldn't concentrate
yeah they put the squeeze on me too
not so much with junior but twins has an
iconic moment and it's anytime
schwarzenegger and danny devito are on
screen together the movie sells itself
just give us a sequel already the rock
gets a chance to show off his ample
charm in journey two when he's teaching
josh hutcherson how to woo the ladies
all you got to do you get a gym
membership you work out every day for 10
years and you make your pecs jump
you can't see because of the shirt but
i'm doing it trust me it's a piece of
cake except you can't eat any cake if
you want to pull that off and i may have
had way too many birthday parties this
year i know the rock's character and
central intelligence can relate to that
because look the opening sequence of
that movie it's a fudgy rock singing in
the shower is it reductionist ryan
reynolds and just friends yes but it's
still comedy gold
arnold can counter this maneuver by
making light of his and sylvester
stallone's frenemy rivalry and last
action hero it's an alternate universe
and it's cemented in our heads when we
see a cardboard cutout at a video store
for terminator 2 starring you guessed it
sly stallone arnold does have a sizeable
advantage in this round but if it seems
pretty even so far it's because i
haven't brought up predator yet the cia
had carl weathers pushing too many
pencils and we were off and running on
an adventure that thrust everything we
love about schwarzenegger to the
forefront exciting action check out the
battle with the rebels and especially
the end fight scene where dutch goes
toe-to-toe in the mud with a badass
alien one-liners this was 1987 which
means peak cool line after offing a guy
or an alien arnold don't disturb my
friend he's dead tired the rock gave a
hell of an effort in this round and i'll
award him some points for his awesome
battle against firefly played by ray
stevenson in gi joe retaliation that
fight lived up to the hype created by my
gi joes in my formative years
or last week but arnold's best scenes
inspired this chubby kid to get out of
the house go into the woods make a fort
and wait for i don't know predator to
come take a shot he never did what were
we doing in the woods besides you know
getting poison oak arnold does win the
round and he goes up two to one
one
two three
i think you're right
round four franchise ability the rock
can't afford to lose another round but
when you hear a world like franchise
ability which again i may or may not
have invented you're welcome miriam
webster you might naturally think of
arnold schwarzenegger after all he's
still recognized as the greatest action
star that ever walked into a gym but
being a bankable franchise centerpiece
takes more than just bronze sunglasses
and someone else's clothes boots and
motorcycle which of these stars were
more fit to build a franchise round
during their respective peaks let's take
a gander dwayne johnson is known as
franchise viagra for a reason he
injected a bolt of energy into the fast
and furious films completely
reinvigorating the property and in doing
so he's down a new spin-off franchise in
that universe okay it's one thing to
have a big star appear in a sequel it's
much more impressive to have those
movies become so successful that we now
have another series of flicks that are
successful just to get you more screen
time on the same universe and that
multiplex cialis isn't limited to just
souped-up automobiles his star power was
the best reason to revive jumanji which
otherwise was a standalone 1990s film
starring the incomparable robin williams
the rock kevin hart and company wisely
didn't try to outdo robin they relied on
their own unique chemistry to make a new
appealing elixir that crushes at the box
office perhaps the most impressive thing
about arnold is that he didn't do too
many franchise type films instead he was
the franchise didn't really matter if he
was a murderous robot or an ancient
warrior or a spy masquerading as a
computer salesman we came to the theater
to see arnold do
whatever he felt like doing the conan
film series established him even though
they weren't necessarily blockbuster
juggernuts and they set the stage for
the terminator movies to become the
preferred tentpole of arnold there's
been six movies to date in that property
with schwarzenegger at least making some
semblance of an appearance in all of
them and to be honest it seemed as if
the franchise has been desperately
clinging to him for any sort of
relevance lately it was refreshing to
see him and linda hamilton back in dark
fate but you also got to wonder why it
took us that long to get a decent sequel
to 1992's terminator 2. oh right he also
made the state of california his
franchise he was governor that really
happened from 2003 to 2011 and naturally
he wasn't focused on hollywood nearly as
much but he would return to help launch
another action franchise featuring
fellow old-timers like sylvester
stallone in the expendables we got more
and more arnold as those sequels piled
up but the box office take was a mere
shadow of prime time arnold he did
launch franchises like predator and
chimed in established series like batman
but he hasn't returned since turning
down an offer to pop into 2016's the
predator if one can applaud arnold for
not jumping at the chance to crank out
sequels every time he made a successful
film we can also lament what if when it
comes to promising starts like true lies
and junior okay i was kidding on the
last one i maybe could have gone for
another kindergarten cop and i'd still
line up to see what jingle all the way
looks like this many years later get
arnold get sinbad but again branching
out the comedy seemed more natural for
the rock and alongside his jumanji buddy
kevin hart they've been able to
franchise themselves as a bankable
comedic force outside the theaters the
rock has also introduced a very
successful line of gym apparel i own one
of his shirts wrote a new york times
bestseller i i don't own that and
launched an astoundingly lucrative
tequila company it even sold more than
george clooney's tequila brand me
personally i'll stick with cabo wabo
because that's how deep my van halen
fandom runs but dwayne johnson has
firmly established himself as his own
standalone franchise in the wrestling
ring and in the business world and then
he makes some movies and back inside
that cineplex both of these fellows
could have done whatever films they
wanted during their lengthy apex at the
top of mount olympus and that includes
winning mr olympia which arnold did
seven times but the proof is in the
pudding which is a horrible analogy
considering neither of these guys have
allowed themselves to eat jello in like
70 years dwayne has actively worked to
get into more franchises solidifying his
lofty perch as one of the last remaining
a-list stars and while arnold
schwarzenegger may never be passed as
the greatest action star of them all
when it comes to franchise ability the
rock edges him out johnson wins the
round and we're tied at 2-2
stop it stop it and now it's time for
the wild card round mono amano sure we
love arnold and the rock for their
legendary characters who've inspired us
all with iconic moments but more than
anything when we walk out of an action
movie we're not just thinking about what
we just witnessed also on our minds is
what's next for this action star or that
intrepid hero and that path will
inevitably lead to one question who wins
in a fight it's schwarzenegger it's
dwayne johnson we've seen them battle
countless enemies and almost always come
out on top and since neither responded
to my request to fight the other person
in studio even though i made it
abundantly clear parking would be made
available i came up with an alternate
battle plan by relying on our expert
researcher mark hoffmeyer you know that
guy when he's not podcasting about deep
blue sea he's drumming up categories
that pits dwayne and arnold's cinematic
accomplishments against each other and i
get to determine the winner it's kind of
like this whole show everyone else does
the heavy lifting and i take all the
credit so let's get to our first heat
the best arm flexing moment okay before
you yell it's predator or nothing please
allow me to remind you that in fast
seven dwayne johnson's character hobbs
was in a cast and then he flexed his way
out proper healing is for suckers let's
get this thing off and save the world
and as impressive as two bulging biceps
exchanging pleasantries is i'm a huge
sports fan and what do sports fans adore
athletes who play through the pain to
get their team a win michael jordan's
flu game walter payton breaking the
single game rushing record with a 103
degree temperature and the rock flexing
his cast off put him in the hall of fame
he gets the nod here best i gotta save
my daughter movie san andreas has
earthquakes wreaking so much havoc on
the west coast that paul giamatti was
forced to dramatically remove his
glasses oh and the rock had to save
various family members including his
daughter a natural disaster is tough to
conquer for sure but so is an entire
army that's who arnold has to mow down
in order to save his daughter alyssa
milano and get her back on the set of
who's the boss mission accomplished and
arnold schwarzenegger is on the board
best johnny knoxville movie it's a tough
call between arnold's the last stand and
dwayne's walking tall but only in the
last stand will you see the jackass star
blow up a guy with a flare gun
definitely do not try that at home
instead go check out arnold's post
gubernatorial era comeback it's a great
action flick best monster movie i'll
exercise satan out of this contest
because then it's not even fair i did
enjoy rampage but come on the answer
here is predator cool locks invisibility
carl weathers is in the movie predator
wins i mean the predator scrimmage
against xenomorphs for goodness sakes
best conan hercules sword and sandal
movie here's where hoffmeier and i got
into a shouting match that threatened
our professional relationship and almost
ruined my chances of one day appearing
on a deep blue sea podcast hoffmeyer
thinks the rock's trifecta of the mummy
returns the scorpion king and hercules
reigns supreme i slide with arnold's two
conan movies and read sonia but since
only one of the above movies is a film
starring brendan fraser i will
begrudgingly give the nod to the rock
here can we please make that the next
verses brendan fraser versus
brigitte nielsen let's do it best kids
movies i had arnold winning this phase
easily on the strength of jingle all the
way alone kindergarten comp is an even
better movie and his icing on the cake
the game plan and the tooth fairy can't
really play with those two but then i
remembered that families like jumanji
like a lot and then you also have that
action franchise that relies on family
i'm leaning with the rock here best odd
pairing film this is basically a scrap
between twins and central intelligence
it's a tie for me so i'm going to lean
towards the movie that set up the
template of the 1980s danny devito
checks into the ball game hits a big
shot and is now heading back to the taxi
stand he's in a sitcom called taxi and
you should all check it out there's a
lot riding on our penultimate
subcategory in this round so we had to
find a competition that truly brings out
the best in an action hero and that
would be their better half it's the best
wife hanging from a helicopter movie
phase and your two entries are true lies
and san andreas now i do want to give
props to san andreas here for a couple
putting aside their differences to save
a lot of civilians but after the movie
ends i just don't see those two making
it work like at all
i give it maybe two weeks but true lies
had true love even if said truth had
been based on a ton of flies that would
ruin most relationships if you need any
evidence that this is an endless romance
it's just that simple wine that arnold
can deliver as well as anyone come on
baby i fully support them as a family of
spies give us the sequel okay we'll do
one more round and this is really the
ultimate question any dude with a gym
membership has ever faced how much can
you bench both arnold and duane have
been cast as hercules so yeah they know
a thing or two about pumping iron i mean
arnold literally stars in a documentary
called pumping iron and he's got his own
lift named after him it's the arnold
press you start out here with a couple
dumbbells and then you go up there it
makes your entire shoulder cry but as
far as the bench press goes who can put
up more pounds according to war dwayne
johnson can bench as many as
450 pounds which means i'm a third of
the way there can mr olympia top that
yes yes he can 500 pounds is arnold's
reported record and that guy still rolls
into venice beach gold's gym to make
some gains i'll see you there dutch
arnold wins this contest and thus the
match three rounds to two this is all
mine it's all me
it's all mine this is all me
thanks for playing
and there you have it kitties arnold is
still the king but for how long dwayne
pushed him to the limit in today's
verses and he still has a ton more
movies to make a gaggle of fast a flock
of furiouses a fleet of cruises a pride
of jumanji's the sky is the limit arnold
has slowed down but just when you think
he's done you'll see him and sylvester
stallone at some red box breaking out of
a crazy high security prison
arnold schwarzenegger wins my vote but
i'm just one person here one person who
recently squatted 225 pounds
once
needed a spot on the second one now it's
your turn dear viewer to register your
opinion on this all-important matter are
you team dwayne or team arnold hit me up
on social media with your take at mark
ellis live and make sure you stay tuned
right here for loads more quality
content from rotten tomatoes my name is
mark ellis and i'll be back
did you smell that line coming it was
pretty obvious and i'm not apologizing
all right everybody
chill
i'll be back
you